Every single thing that I've done has
been possible because of my parents,
because of my incredible family.
My mom is originally from Guatemala City,
Guatemala; my dad is originally from Nayarit,
Mexico. They both came to the U.S. very
very young, on their own, searching
something bigger, they wanted to better
their lives.
One of the biggest reasons I
think that social justice has become
such a huge driving force for me, such a
huge passion is growing up with the
stories of my parents, undocumented
immigrants trying to live in a country
that they've never been before, just
trying to survive, just trying to get by.
The struggles and the humiliations that
they had to face because of that, that
doesn't seem okay to me, that doesn't
feel right.
Compassion, humility, honor, honesty, hard
work, perseverance, core values that I
hold because of my family.
Class of 2017,
congratulations!
[cheering]
I think there are so many different
experiences and dynamics and identities
that are represented at Harvard that
historically just were not there. Often
times it can be these unique points of
view that are challenging Harvard to
grow and to shift and to become more
dynamic.
Getting to hold that piece of paper in
our hands that says this is how we are
going to aid you, you know where I'm
coming from and you know the type of
background that I'm coming from, you
still believe that we want to bring you
here and contribute to our campus and
learn as much as you can and take
advantage of these opportunities, it
helps make it more real.
Launching very much into this career of
working at nonprofits, I hope that I can
truly and firmly say that I've done
everything I can to minimize what I
consider unnecessary and unjust struggle
to impact and better the lived
experiences of others. Those are the
things I'm working towards.